here's what would happen if Earth's
surface was inverted
since 71 percent of earth's surface is
water the seven continents would become
oceans and the seabed would become one
big interconnected land mass besides the
Mariana mountain range the former
Mariana Trench our upside down world
would be a huge plateau
our inverted continents would be four
times higher than currency level and
we'd have to adapt to living in a low
oxygen environment if we wanted to
survive you'd be able to walk to any
part of the world but our oceans control
our climate Distributing heat from the
Sun evenly throughout the planet now
with less water surface most of the land
would become a scorching desert also
greenhouse gases would build up and stay
in the atmosphere slowly cooking the
planet there'd be no fresh water left to
drink plants would die and all the
animals would too because